welcome to this video one playing in
five minute game and I'm really
dangerously low and close to being below
2,200 really in bad shape at the moment
here I'm playing a prep games and then
lose them all I don't know I'm playing
her just total nonsense let's hope it it
gets better this is some may be going to
a Catalan or Norway's playing deform so
we yeah maybe go for reverse benko at
least I know what to do in this type of
position and with them this should be a
rather decent version of that reverse
Bank oh yeah he returned the pawn
immediately and allowed me to play
Bishop g5 that's rather nice and now
maybe activate the night C to B form
this is this route
that's quite nice and now here to intent
95 it's a nice square okay yeah not so
obvious how to continue now maybe could
be five a grenade for Queen B 5 nice not
really reacting to it maybe see five
nights savoia that's actually good
maybe Knight a5 coming of the night I
sect of them yeah somewhat uh Nesta
mated this I thought d4 is weak which it
yeah again just which it is Emma
probably doesn't even just a bishop f6
coming
yeah I want to activate the Queen now in
trading it's not something that I fear
and the CERN this particular position
d3m probably at some point you will play
Bishop f6 I want to get out of this long
diagonal you know to be six it should be
a nice structure if it takes pawn takes
and c5 very dangerous some potentially
very dangerous pawns now I don't think
you should trade him okay avoided that
yeah there's always Bishop f6 coming
yeah all this one but the rookie anubis
not protecting deform which I will
attack with rocket etool not sure about
Ruger six
hey I'm not just winning this yeah yeah
you will get the the torques but still
how do i do i enter with the Queen now I
think I think I'm very okay yeah but how
do i enter with the Queen looked you one
is also slight problem and ce4 is
hanging hmm
qe3 and Bishop f1 i don't i don't know i
don't like to return this prana he
doesn't take it I think you should have
taken it this this looks weird this a
green trap I can't believe it really you
travel unbelievable yeah this is this is
happening when you're in a bed run the
queen is just wrapped unbelievable oh if
I just play any other move Black is
busted I just busted white resigns yeah
Kim G to I mean of course I want to make
this this Bishop boom yeah that it came
freaking b5 roo k for that this is just
just totally winning for what I just
thought of all the time in the world
which I have not okay one thus
kindergarten threat striking oh my god
yeah yeah it was a pretty pretty young
equal position I think Luke f6 was still
still a bit strange but when he allowed
that why this white is simply better and
after this he of course must just take
check but ok didn't do that yeah and
here I mean beef beef I've is probably
the strongest only not kingi to be five
promise he cannot take a screen b6
assume it's just winning on the spot
well and then why it is just much better
with this advanced pawns something like
that check an example may I can maybe
you can hold that but the problem is his
exposed structure here if the pawns go
back it can easily be a fortress but
like that he's probably just just
flat-out losing yeah but if your
blundering the Queen it does not help
thanks for watching